as the release state-of-the-art x20 DTI
is getting closer and closer there are
more and more leaks about its
performance and benchmarks and
unfortunately they aren't looking too
good
[Music]
welcome to Horus hobbies so our first
performance right here is coming from ei
dices new battlefield 2 pi which is
going to be coming out in just two
months and a Christian Holmquist who is
the technical director of dice stated
that they needed to download back
ray-tracing in order to increase frame
rates and make images look more credible
christian claims that they have been
working very hard to implement ray
tracing technology without hurting FPS
and the best way they have thought do
this is increased to minimum system
requirements and utilize more cores now
this is not too bad because most people
buying an RT x-series card already have
high level CPUs as well christian
finally states
they're targeting 1920 by 1080p at 60
frames per second with ray tracing
technology enabled now he doesn't
specify what cards is for this level of
performance would actually be okay for
the RT x 2070 60 frames per second at
1080p for ray tracing technology enabled
for a $500 card is actually not that bad
especially considering that it is such a
demanding game with that type of
performance in rate range technology is
a really good sign for traditional
gaming as well however the bad thing is
is that this may be the target for
higher-level cards like the Arctic's
2080 or RT x 20 atti based on other
performance leaks so it may not be
looking so good for the 20 series this
similar trend continues with other games
as well PC games and soft luxuriating
FPS from 33 FPS to 48 FPS on shadow of
the Tomb Raider when they were demoing
it now this is for the RT X 20 atti
and I know that this is just a demo and
there'll be more optimisation driver
updates but really how far can
optimization and driver updates really
take rate racing technology to me it
seems like the shadow of a Tomb Raider
team will also have to dial back great
racing technology
in order to just reach 60
frames-per-second by the looks of this
it seemed as if all top-level modern
games will have trouble reaching 60
frames per second at just 1080p with
retraining technology enabled even for
the $1200 RTX 2080 TI and this is just
the beginning of its lifetime imagine
that year or two later when in-game for
even more advanced will the artist when
atti ik struggle to even push 30 frames
per second at that point so this is all
the performance data that we have but
what exactly does this mean
well basically impedes expecting us to
pay $1200 for the performance that we
would usually expect out of a GTX 1060
now I know the GTX 1060 does not have
great racing technology and while rate
rosy technology look absolutely
spectacular and it is really hard to
render in the end it is just shadows and
little reflections here and there as a
result I'm pretty sure that 99.9% of
gamers would take higher resolution over
great racing technology any day of the
week
and people who are buying art txseries
cards most likely don't game at 1080p
they mostly have 1440p or 4k monitors so
in the end while they may play with that
the beginning to see how it makes heard
games look at low resolutions in the end
they'll probably just turn it off in
order to game high resolutions and at
that point the 20 series and rate crazy
technology is pretty much completely
pointless
what's 2.0 by an art text card if you're
just gonna use it for traditional gaming
for example you can just rather than go
out and get a gtx 280 TI which is right
now it's $600 which is half the price of
the art kx1 atti
and i can tell you right now without
looking at anything that archaic 20 dt I
will not have double the performance of
the GTX an ATI in terms of traditional
gaming performance so at that point the
GTX 280 TI would be the clear winner
honestly right now Ray Creative
Technology does seem like a gimmick that
no one would really ever use even the
top level cards can't really handle it
well and most games won't even support
it even people who are buying these
cards specifically for the great race
technology probably won't use it for a
good portion of their gaming time in the
end is seeing that the Harvard just
isn't quite ready to handle
high level rendering and right now at
least most people who are buying the
Arctic series of cards will most likely
just use it for normal gaming as a
result it seems like it is way too early
for greater ease and technology and
it'll be much better suited for the next
generation of cards and right now it is
probably just better to get a 10 series
equivalent of the 20 series car that you
want in terms of traditional gaming
performance because the extra cost for
rate crazy technology is simply not
worth it
but again the best thing to do right now
is to just wait for the benchmarks to
come out for the new twenty series cards
before making any decisions online
while these reports are coming from
really reliable sources there may be
something big that we are still missing
for example the 20 series may be so good
at gaming that it is still worth its
high price the 20 DTI
may be able to handle 4k at 144 frames
plus easily and ray-tracing is just the
icing on the cake but only time will
tell so what do you guys think are you
going to be getting a 20 Series card and
do you think in video will launch these
same cards without the braid trees and
Technology for example a gtx 2080 and
the gtx 22t I make sure comment down
below what you guys think because I do
read all my comments I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like to
be a dimeric drop a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Applause]
[Music]